[Music]
do you know how many titles your
character has on well every season I get
some more as well so I think that's it
your well that it yeah well I've got
some I mean I don't know if you how many
of these you know there's a bunch that I
didn't know hmm yours
sue I'm born the first of her name yep
queen of Miron Queen of Marine marine
sorry please sorry oh well better watch
it and Dragons right unite around South
merchants lady regnant of the Seven
Kingdoms I didn't know crazy regent of
the Seven Kingdoms here's the people I
have working for me get in tight I
didn't know what regnant was I thought
it was some sort of you know Dothraki
word well-fed pregnant and then I just
looked like a [ __ ]
I just read exactly what I'm told that's
okay that's okay
I should have been quiet and then you
would have been there no one would
question do no no you did exactly the
right what you're supposed to this show
for the piece of [ __ ] it can sometimes
[Applause]
say that about yourself yeah yeah yeah
do the queen or regnant I can teach them
about it we can have that one
you